the Armed Forces fought a successful
military campaign which took Basra and
helped to achieve the departure of
Saddam Hussein and the fall of Baghdad
in less than a month service personnel
civilians who deployed to Iraq and
Iraqis who worked for the UK showed
great courage in the face of
considerable risks and they deserve our
gratitude and respect more than 200
British citizens died as a result of a
conflict in Iraq many more were injured
this has meant deep anguish for many
families including those who are here
today after the invasion the UK and the
u.s. became joint occupying powers for
the year that followed
Iraq was governed by the Coalition
Provisional Authority the UK was fully
implicated in the authority's decisions
but struggled to have a decisive effect
on its policies the government's
preparations failed to take account of
the magnitude of the task of stabilizing
administering and reconstructing Iraq
and of the responsibilities which were
likely to fall to the UK the UK took
particular responsibility for four
provinces in the southeast it did so
without a formal ministerial decision
and without ensuring that it had the
necessary military and civilian
capabilities to discharge its
obligations including crucially to
provide security the scale of the UK
effort in post-conflict Iraq never
matched the scale of the challenge
Whitehall departments and their
ministers failed to put collective
weight behind the tasks the security
situation in both Baghdad and the
southeast began to deteriorate
soon after the invade
we have found that the Ministry of
Defense was slow in responding to the
threat from improvised explosive devices
and that delays in providing adequate
medium-weight protected patrol vehicles
should not have been tolerated it is not
clear which person or department within
the Ministry of Defense was responsible
for identifying and articulating such
capability gaps but it should have been
from 2006 the UK military was conducting
two enduring campaigns in Iraq and
Afghanistan it did not have sufficient
resources to do so
decisions on resources for Iraq were
affected by the demands of the operation
in Afghanistan we have sought to set out
the government's actions on Iraq fully
and impartially the evidence is there
for all to see it is an account of an
intervention which went badly wrong with
consequences to this day the enquiry
report is the committee's unanimous view
military action in Iraq might have been
necessary at some point but in March
2003 there was no imminent threat from
Saddam Hussein the strategy of
containment could have been adapted and
continued for some time the majority of
the Security Council supported
continuing UN inspections and monitoring
military intervention elsewhere may be
required in the future a vital purpose
of the inquiry is to identify what
lessons should be learned from
experience in Iraq the UK's relationship
with the US has proved strong enough
over time to bear the weight of honest
disagreement it does not require
unconditional support where our interest
or judgments differ
the lessons also include the importance
of collective ministerial discussion
which encourages frank and informed
debate and challenge the need to assess
risks weigh options and set an
achievable and realistic strategy the
vital role of ministerial leadership and
coordination of action across government
supported by senior officials the need
to ensure that both civilian and
military arms of government are properly
equipped for their tasks above all the
lesson is that all aspects of any
intervention need to be calculated
debated and challenged with the utmost
rigor and when decisions have been made
they need to be implemented fully sadly
neither was the case in relation to the
UK government's actions